chances are where you are in your
architectural career right now in 2020
i've been there and today i really want
to give you
some invaluable advice
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
for those of you who don't know me i'm a
masters of architecture graduate
currently undergoing my final
registration process to become a fully
registered architect
in australia today i wanted to take the
time to talk to you about your
architectural journey and what you're
about to experience
over the next five years if you're just
starting out
it is one hell of a journey it is
something that you will definitely
remember for the rest of your life
but there's a few things i wish people
told me before i got started
if you've been subscribed to the channel
for a little while now first thank you
so much
if you haven't subscribe button's just
there but you'll probably
be aware of the fact that recently i
ruptured my achilles tendon
well last time i said that i was going
to see the physio and the specialist
and yes i have gotten out of the cast
i'm in a moon boot
it was one of the most painful
experiences i've experienced in a very
long time
but progress is progress and i'm slowly
making my way
back to being able to walk and be on my
feet again so
very good news anyway enough about me
and my life story
let's get on with today's video so my
number one piece of advice
is prepare to be uncomfortable from
somebody who considers himself an
introvert
i thought architecture school was one of
the most challenging
social aspects i've ever been exposed to
and that's because my tutors and my
peers around me
really really pushed me let me give you
an example on my very first day
at architecture school it was day one
studio
number one it was the most out of the
box studio that we've ever done
but what we actually did for that studio
was nude
live model sketches yup you heard me
right
nude live model sketches was the very
first
day of architecture school not many
people say on the first day of
university
their tutors put nude people in front of
them we were split up into three
different classes because it was a
pretty big architecture group
and we each got one live subject that we
had to sketch
and try to get ourselves to understand
the human form
now there are a number of lessons in
this but the predominant one that i took
out of it after reflecting on it
many many years later was the fact that
architecture is a very
uncomfortable profession and you have to
be ready to come out of your shell
if you're somebody who is like i was a
very much an introvert
you are going to get exposed to many
many things and you are going to be
criticized
a lot i can't stress that last point
enough
architecture is such an opinionated
subject that it doesn't matter what you
design
somebody is going to think it is the
worst thing ever it's very similar to
being on youtube actually
you might put out the best video ever
but i guarantee you there's going to be
a number of people
that comment worst thing you've ever put
out but hey
everybody's entitled to their own
opinion it's just something that we have
to get comfortable with
as people in the profession number two
if you think you need
the skills and ability to draw like an
artist well
you've definitely got that wrong
architecture is no longer about your
skills on drawing on paper
yes there are still some elements and
some schools that do teach
the manual arts and the technical
drawing which is fantastic because it's
a great skill to have
but you don't have to be technically
perfect to be
a good architect or even a good
architecture student in my personal
opinion
now in 2020 the most important thing
that you're going to learn in
architecture school
is the technology side of things
architecture has progressed so much
that all and i mean literally all of
our documentation is done on a computer
from sketch design
all the way through to final
construction documentation you do not
need to pick up a pencil
ever in your architecture career to be a
good
architect again there is some value in
it you can sketch in front of clients
for example
and try to figure out problems in front
of builders
but overall as a general skill it isn't
the number one on your list
that you must know how to draw i think
what is more important
is one understanding technology and
understanding
how to use these programs which
obviously come through practice and
repetition
same way as drawing did back in the day
i think number two what you'll find is a
lot of architecture students get into
photography and videography
very early on now this is because it
lets you express your creative freedom
and understand
the building as a whole which we'll get
to a little bit later because the
building
isn't actually what makes good
architecture i think if you're willing
to venture again
out of your comfort zone and learn
technology learn some photography and
videography skills
you're gonna do exceptionally well at
architecture school
okay so i just said architecture isn't
about buildings
which brings me to point number three so
point number three you have to be
really really good at hitting that like
button and smashing that subscribe
button
no i'm just kidding but i would really
appreciate it if you hit that like
button for me
architecture is about yes the building
itself
but it's more so about the building and
how the building functions
how the spaces work how the flow works
who it's designed for
and why it has been designed there is
absolutely no point
designing a one million person stadium
in a town that only has a hundred
thousand people
yes they may have the budget the
capabilities the facilities whatever
but you need to know what this building
is
specifically being designed for so my
first year of architecture school i
couldn't grasp this concept
i always started drawing some cool
little abstract buildings and i was like
yeah this is gonna do really really well
and well i got average grades in my
first year i'm not gonna lie it wasn't
the best
until i got some really good tutors and
some really insightful people
that sat me down and went david this
isn't
architecture architecture isn't just
about how pretty the building is
you really have to walk through it
experience it
understand it and create a journey out
of that whole experience
now that word journey actually defined
my thesis project
but more so to the fact was that i
started to understand
how this was related to architecture and
the building itself so a very famous
example is le corbusier's human figure
it's the guy standing up like this i'm
sure you've seen it already if you
haven't you will see it probably
very early on into your architecture
days this little figure is
absolutely critical and pivotal to any
design that you do in the early days
i'd suggest cutting out this little guy
and placing him
into every single little abstract design
that you do
to understand that space you have to
stop designing
in a 2d floor plan point of view
and actually start imagining this space
in 3d
and in section so the le caboosia figure
for example
off the top of my head i believe stands
at 2250
which means 2250 is your more
comfortable space for most of humanity
live in
if you can't get these spaces or you're
trying to create something different
then that's a whole other story but
again it brings it back to the point
that these spaces
are designed for the people that
interact with it they're designed
from the floor plan itself to the height
of the walls to the width of the room
to absolutely everything how you flow
through the building
is also critical and then when you get
really into the fine details it becomes
about materiality and texture
understanding that a transition in
materiality
could signify something very important
in the building
if it's a museum it could signify from
one decade
to another or one century to another
there is
many many ways of transitioning between
spaces
on a more i guess emotional level than a
very physical level
so stop thinking that architecture is
just about buildings
yes it is but it's more about the people
the spaces and the places
number four if you're not a people
person again get comfortable
you're going to be working in teams a
lot throughout your architecture career
there is nobody that i know in the world
that can do
everything themselves from the very
first day to the very last day
working in teams in an architecture
environment is
the general day-to-day norm so you're
going to have to find
some very good friends at the start who
you're going to be able to team up with
later on during your degrees these
people will probably end up being some
of the best friends you have for the
rest of your life
you'll create some incredible memories
and also some incredible architecture
along the way
yes you all have your own diverse style
of architecture
and you'll all eventually be very
different architects one day
but at the end of the day you would have
shared those experiences together
gone through those hard yards together
and made those memories
together now my last tip is something
that's a bit unique to architecture
if you're an architecture student sleep
is the most
vital thing that you can get but it's
also
the biggest unicorn in architecture
school i don't know why it is and i
don't know why
architecture students can't control
their time management
because i was very good at controlling
time management
during university i ended up running
multiple businesses working full-time
running my degree full time and
completing everything successfully
so i knew time management very very well
but at the same time
i spent 48 hours once wide awake
non-stop at my laptop doing this
final project for submission i was
miles ahead in my head before i started
but i think the one thing that you find
in architecture school is
there's always something that can be
improved so you'll finish a floor plan
and then you'll improve it
and then you'll finish an elevation and
then you'll improve it and you'll finish
the section and then you'll improve it
and you'll just keep improving that
project
until the very last minute that it has
to be submitted
because you really become passionate
about these projects
they become everything for you you're
consumed by them
it's three to six months of your life of
analyzing
this project and understanding every
detail about it
yours specifically and then presenting
your heart and soul to people who are
probably going to rip it apart
but that's a good thing don't feel
discouraged when they do rip it apart
because that
is a pivotal learning experience
understanding
where the faults are in these designs is
what's going to make you
a much much better architect in the
future so whenever you can get a spare
moment to sleep
make sure you do rest and recover
because
being at university for 24 48 hours
wide awake straight is very unhealthy
and very dangerous
so if you are there for long periods of
time
find somewhere that you can sleep
because we've all done it
there's no judgment there you will end
up sleeping at the architecture building
hands down guaranteed i've fallen asleep
on chairs
in random studios in a hammock once
just i said to the guys i'm gonna go lay
down for 30 seconds
next minute it was three hours later
because i'd been awake
for 36 hours for that project i think
so yeah get the sleep and make sure you
get good nights
when you can anyway that's all from me
today guys i hope you enjoyed the video
i hope i gave you some good insight into
what architecture school is going to be
like
don't get me wrong don't be put off by
this topic it is an amazing experience
and it is some of the best years you
will have of your life
you will develop some amazing skills and
create some amazing friendships if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
the like button
to help this video get shared around
youtube and help it with the algorithm
hit the subscribe button if you want to
see more of these videos
and as always i will see you next monday